والى الموجود في حي النصر قرب غزه هذا
الحي ربما الذي يشيع فيه
القيادي في سرايا القدس
الذراع العسكري لحركه الجهاد الذي استشهد
امس مع مرافقه وهو القائد اياد الحسني
وائل
نعم اسمعك جيدا
اذا
هو تشييع الشهيد القيادي اياد الحسني في
حي النصر اليس كذلك وائل
هذا صحيح نحن هنا في منطقه ما بين حي
النصر ومخيم الشاطئ غرب مدينه غزه
وهنا حشود من المواطنين الفلسطينيين
يجتمعون في هذا المكان في منطقه عراء
وربما
يعني اتخذوا ربما قرارا لاقامه مراسم
التشييع في هذه المنطقه
الفراغ وبالتالي تتجمع الناس شيئا فشيئا
في هذا المكان
ومنذ ان وصلنا الى هذا المكان راينا ان
الكلمات تتلى من قبل مختلف الفصائل
الفلسطينيه
الجثامين جثمان الشهيد القائد اياد الحسني
قائد وحده العمليات في سرايا القدس
ومرافقه
يسجون يسجيان هنا في هذا
المعرش الصغير
وكما تشاهدون في محيطه رايات لكل الفصائل
الفلسطينيه والاعلام الفلسطينيه ايضا فيما
المواطنون
وانصار ربما واحباب الشهيد او الشهيدين
يلقون نظره الوداع الاخير على
جثماني الشهيدين
ويعني ويستمعون الى الكلمات وذلك وصولا
الى رفع اذان الظهر بعد دقائق معدوده ومن
ثم اقامه صلاه الظهر قبل ان تقام صلاه
الجنازه على جثماني الشهيدين
وربما استمعنا للتو الى طلقات ناريه ربما
اطلقها بعض المسلحين
تعبيرا عن حاله الغضب التي تسيطر على جموع
جمال الجماهير الموجوده في هذه المنطقه
التي ربما مضمون الكلمات التي استمعنا
اليها سواء مزيد من الطلقات والرصاصات في
الهواء بطبيعه الحال مضمون مضامين الكلمات
التي استمعنا اليها سواء تلك التي صدرت عن
الجهاد الاسلامي او حركه فتح او حركه حماس
او حتى كت المجاهدين هذه الكلمات التي
تتلى على مسامع الجمهور الموجود هنا في
هذه المنطقه منطقه تشييع الشهداء بالتاكيد
ركزت في فيما يبدو وكانها نبره واحده
وموقف شبه واحد هو ان
سياسه الاغتيال سواء طالت اسماء بحجم اياد
الحسنه او غيرهم من القيادات في اذرع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه لن تدفع الفصائل
الفلسطينيه ولا غرفه العمليات المشتركه
ولا حتى سرايا القدس الى التراجع ولن تكسر
من عزيمتها ولن تشل حركتها وفاعليتها في
الميدان على العكس من ذلك هذه الكلمات
تؤكد تباعا بان هذه الاغتيالات تزيد من
عزيمه الفصائل الفلسطينيه
وتدفعهم الى يعني ربما مزيد من الفعل في
الميدان واطلاق الرشاشات الرشاقات
الصاروخيه انتقاما لسياسه الاغتيال
انتقاما لارتقاء الشهداء الفلسطينيين ومن
بينهم بطبيعه الاحوال هي الاسماء الكبيره
وعلى راسهم بالتاكيد نحن نتحدث هنا عن
حادثه الاغتيال التي تمكنت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من خلالها من اغتيال اياد
الحسني القيادي البارز في سرايا القدس